lots of washington insiders claim to be
washington outsiders because it sounds
good one thing you can say about
marjorie taylor green
she really is a washington outsider as
close as you'll find in congress that's
for sure
and that means that she often notices
things that people have been there for a
long time
miss and that's what happened earlier
this week when marjory taylor green
found something
lurking in an infrastructure bill that
democrats have written that bill states
this quote
women shall be presumed to be socially
and economically disadvantaged
disadvantaged individuals for the
purposes of this subsection
well that was news to marjorie taylor
green so she tweeted this quote my
construction company is woman owned and
i'm very offended to be presumed
socially and economically disadvantaged
end quote we checked and it turns out
that
many government laws assume that women
the majority of the american population
are quote
economically disadvantaged what is that
congresswoman margie taylor green joins
us tonight congresswoman thanks so much
for coming on so how surprised were you
to learn
in this bill that you're a victim
well i wasn't just surprised i was
outraged as a matter of fact i'm i'm
very angry about it
because i can tell you this i'm probably
one of the only members of congress
that owns a woman-owned construction
company
i've been successful in 11 states we've
done a lot of money in revenue i can say
a lot more than the federal government
and we know how to turn a profit not a
loss and i can tell you
as a member of congress who's been
successful in business
i'm not only surprised i am very angered
to be considered in a category that is
socially
and economically disadvantaged because
as a matter of fact
i don't consider myself that way at all
i consider myself one of the luckiest
women on the planet because
i'm an american woman and i live in a
country
where through hard work i can be
successful and that's exactly what we've
done
in our family construction business that
is a woman-owned business
and so for democrats to treat women and
put us down in a category
where we have to be a victim in order to
succeed
i find that extremely insulting and i
see it as a continuation as the
democrats war
on women well it's a little strange too
because most americans
are women so how can you have an
oppressed minority that's actually the
majority
of the country i mean it doesn't kind of
make any sense does it
no it doesn't make sense but this is how
democrats
achieve their agenda they have to divide
everyone up in some sort of political
identity
whether you're a woman you're you're
lgbtq
xyz whatever transgender black hispanic
asian they have to divide everyone up
they have to make you know give you the
message that you're a victim
and you can't be successful unless
you're using
their policy or their government program
that they're going to provide to you
at a cost to the american taxpayers and
that's how you will be successful
you see they don't believe in individual
rights they don't believe in our
freedoms
and they don't believe in americans
independent
will and hard work to be successful
that's not who the democrat party is
they're the party of socialism and
that's why in every single bill i read
and believe me i read them
because as a business owner i'm used to
actually reading contracts
and reading information and anything i
sign my name on
and that's why in this transportation
bill i was completely
shocked and angered and insulted frankly
as a woman who has been successful
in the construction industry you see
what democrats want in this
this disgusting infrastructure bill that
they just got through the senate and
biden announced that they have a
have a deal for you see what they want
is they want a transfer of wealth
and they don't want to give contracts to
transportation companies to trucking
companies to paving companies
that are able to actually do the job and
do the job well
they want to provide it to
minority-owned companies
or women-owned companies who they
consider are socially and economically
disadvantaged
and this is everything wrong with the
democrats policies and that's why i'm
very much against it
yeah the party of rich ladies telling
you that ladies are oppressed
i love it i can't believe you read the
bill
boy you are new to this you're probably
the only one who did margie taylor green
thanks for coming on i appreciate it
thank you tucker hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else